John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's actually Monday.
We just got to London, the game starts in
a few hours, I'm incredibly well-rested.
I think it speaks to how dramatically my life
has changed since I had children that one
of the best nights of sleep I've had in years
occurred on an airplane.
But I feel great, everybody's excited for
the game.
Sarah and Rosianna : Yay!
John: Hank, it's becoming harder and harder
to make the case that the Yeti is a yeti.
We're making a quick visit to the Saatchi
Gallery because you can't go to London and
not look at art.
Alright Hank, it is now 3:30 and therefore
getting dark in England, and we're on our
way to the game.
It doesn't start for 5 hours, but we're on
our way!
Here we are Hank, we have arrived for the
big game, I've gotten my match day scarves.
So excited!
Alright Hank, I have, uh, now acquired basically
the entire AFC Wimbledon club shop.
Clerk: If only he had bought all the stock!
(John and clerk laugh).
John: Alright Hank, now we're at the bar.
Um, we're going to have a couple pints- I
believe I used that term correctly- before
the game starts.
These are the actual gloves that Seb Brown
used to save those two penalties against Luton
Town to send Wimbledon back into the league.
And of course, Hank, we are in the official
match day program.
Hank, it's happening!
It's real!
This is-gaaaah!
We sponsor a team that's playing Liverpool!
I know that you don't share my excitement
in this so it seems a little foreign to you,
but it's just- it- I don't want to say it's
the best day of my life because I have two
children, the day of their births was amazing,
my wedding day was wonderful- But it's a best
day of my life, you know what I mean?
Okay Hank, the game is about to start.
Sarah is doing weird things by my face.
Man: Wombles!
Woman: COME ON YOU DONS!
Crowd: AFC WIMBLEDON!
Man: Come on you Dons!
John: Okay Hank we're here.
I'm like 45 feet away from Steven Gerrard.
Okay Hank Liverpool scored that was very stressful
but then Wimbledon scored so now it's 1-1
- it's just incredibly exciting.
I've never been this excited ever.
There's like a minute left in the first half.
It's not a foul he's just a larger person!
There's about 5 minutes left.
Liverpool is winning thanks to a Steven Gerrard
free kick.
It's hard to root against that.
There's Barry Fuller or as I call him on the
Wimbly Womblys Buckminster Fuller.
This is incredibly exciting.
There's a Liverpool player taking a corner
from in front of the word Nerdfighter.
Crowd: Boo!
Boo!
Ya!
Man: Playing for a tie against a team three
divisions below you!
John: So Hank after an immensely entertaining
game in which I found myself in the unusual
position of having to root against a Steven
Gerrard goal, AFC Wimbledon have done themselves
proud and technically lost.
And now Hank it's the next morning, it's a
very strange thing to have my favorite player,
Steven Gerrard, score two goals to beat AFC
Wimbledon, but I have to say that was the
absolute time of my life.
Thanks to everyone at Wimbledon for hosting
us and showing us such a great time, and thanks
to everyone who watched the game and sent
in all their pictures of the DFTBAs and Nerdfighterias
all over the pitch.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.